hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i'm going to be
talking about the recovery
loan scheme and how that is potentially
going to affect the property market
and also can you access it can you get
hold of
the money they're giving out loans of up
to 10
million pounds to businesses to help
them recover
from the pandemic and the lockdown so
if you enjoy my channel if you enjoy the
information that i give on the channel
please do me a massive favor before
watching this video
and just hit the like button that would
be much appreciated and of course don't
forget to subscribe
and turn the notification bell on so
bounce back loans bounce back loans have
now ended and they've ended uh some time
back now and if you remember about eight
months ago
last year i was advising everybody to
get a bounce-back loan
as long as you knew how to invest that
money and there was a lot of controversy
controversy about this because people
were saying you can't get a bounce back
loan and invest in property
and of course i said it just depends on
the term of the loan
and there was a lot of gray area but as
a result of the bounce back loans and
other things
property market boomed and i think one
of the reasons the property
market boomed is because it's like the
opposite of 2008
in 2008 the banks stopped giving out
money
and because they were not giving
mortgages and they weren't giving loans
the people couldn't then buy the
properties unless they're buying them
cash
therefore property prices absolutely
crash that's what happened in the uk
in 2008 i remember it because i was
buying properties around about the time
and now kind of the opposite has
happened
yes there's been fear but the the
government and the banks and lenders
have been
giving out money like absolutely crazy
first the banks back loans now they've
ended
now the recovery loan scheme so are you
eligible for
a loan on the recovery loan scheme
firstly first thing is this they're very
very clear
that you cannot take a recovery loan
for your business and use that money to
invest it
in property so you can't do that
will some people do it probably how
strict are they i don't know but i would
just recommend don't do it
however i do think it's going to
continue pushing up house prices
because if you're a business and you've
got money here
it's going to free up money here so you
can't deny that
anything there's anything that's pumping
money into the economy and any any
businesses that are getting more money
it's going to probably mean that they
can continue buying houses
so i think the property prices probably
not just because of this but also for
other reasons probably will continue
rising
for the foreseeable of course they're
then going to fall
of course they're then going to bounce
back up again because this is what house
prices always do
are you eligible for a recovery loan it
depends on your business and it depends
on your
track record they are asking for
business plans they're asking for
historical data and accounts
so it is tougher than a bounce back loan
is however
if you're a business owner that's a
property business you can't take money
and invest in property but if you've got
a
deal sourcing business and it's going
well or a rent to rent company or a
letting agency
you can apply for a recovery loan
if you can demonstrate that your
business has been affected because of
the
the last 12 months or so you can apply
so
my advice would be always
look into it and apply for a recovery
loan because there's a lot of almost
free money being handed out
and of course that's going to mean that
you can put that back into your business
you can grow the business
and and the bounce back loans were 2
interest a year the recovery
loans do vary but they're not allowed to
be more than 14.99 that's very high
but if you've got the opportunity as a
business to get a
loan and it's going to help you bounce
back it's going to help you recover your
business
then i would say absolutely look into
doing it have to be a business have to
be a trading business not a property
investment business but a a property
development business would be okay
or deal sourcing management rent to rent
if you're a trading business you can
apply for it
so that is what the recovery loan scheme
is
i hope you found this video helpful i'm
going to leave
more details in the description with
some more information about the
recovery loan scheme i'm also going to
include a link to the website where you
can
apply investigate and find out more
information on this because
wouldn't it be great if you applied got
some money were able to flourish
use the money well and and this video
helped you do that
uh if if if you can't apply or you
haven't got a trading business then at
least you know exactly where you stand
and what the crack is hope that was
helpful thanks for watching and i'll be
back with more videos real soon
was